welcome to this video playing chromos
from Norway I play them five times no
eight times with five wins three losses
no draw so very very fighting games now
this is a pretty pretty decent line for
black some quite quite quite quite
playable I have no no greater recipe
against it and there are nobody has
maybe I can is this an idea will see 5
here then b4 b5 okay I need to go go
with something now this might be okay
it's nothing nothing brilliant but I
maybe get in get in this get in b5
interesting
yeah sometimes you have technical ideas
here but I don't think this is the case
like with b5 and P sacrifices taking on
c7 b5 it it's not it's not on here and
probably okay when was chief 5 i'm going
to take and play form wanted to have an
f6 in first
ah it feels like there might be
something in this position I'm in some
sort of attacking idea I have a very
good very good development here with be
five maybe something with b5 and and P
sacrifices it's very close to working
okay let's not let's not spend ages here
and go for that it might not work but it
looks it looks very interesting now the
idea is not just to take but also kade
trying to or here r uu k 7 going for
thorn attack look h7 here maybe just has
booked be aged 22 defend him
ok
okay it probably probably was a bit too
much hit the sacrifice cannot go see six
I 97's especially awkward 9726 no this
wasn't a good idea truly wasn't also
look a 7 was a stupid move it runs right
into this 96 business
now I should have played it slow this
was possible it was a wasn't ok position
ok 95 I cannot cannot make work really
yeah not good it's not easy yet totally
easy for for black to convert but maybe
maybe I still get get some play him
maybe I can do something with c6 it's at
least active I mean it's not enough I'm
not saying a half compensation here
don't get me wrong but I think it it was
worse c66 axiom I take it and 95 or
time 195 is one possibility ok I can
maybe return it with 96 or something oh
it's not doing it just basically
claiming that I'm not threatening
anything which is maybe true going for
c7 here maybe can go Bishop deform
yeah that's really not working at all
there are many many ways to review this
Bishop g4 whatever
there's a quality as well maybe I can
get some pawns
yeah okay white resign I had lost you
better the sacrifice I don't know it's
it's it's probably not correct i I
really what I didn't see is that 97 I
was I was hoping for this year and
before 93 this is the situation but he
has always 97 mrs. it's just totally
wrong as a sacrifice and it's it's also
not necessary because with normal moves
I just have a good position like yes I
don't know it's it looks fairly normal I
can just play this yeah just just such a
terrible idea may I just not working
what can I do okay thanks for watching